in the last video we saw how everyone in
country a got excited about investing in
country b and so they wanted to convert
their currency into country b's currency
and left to its own devices with this
new demand for currency b it would have
made currency b more expensive but
instead of allowing that to happen the
central bank of country b said no no no
i want to keep the exchange rates
relatively stable so i'm going to print
b's and use those to buy up a's and so
at the end of that video the central
bank of country b ended up with foreign
currency reserves it ended up with it
ended up with some of a's currency on
its balance sheet what i want to do in
this video is think about what happens
if if kind of demand goes the other way
and how could the central bank use its
foreign currency reserves to prevent its
currency from devaluing so let's go to a
net the next stage in this our little
hypothetical story here let's say people
in a so all this investment happened in
country b everyone was all excited uh
probably a bubble was forming of some
kind
and then all of a sudden people the
investors in country start to get a
little bit scared they start to hear
reports of the bubble forming they start
to realize that conditions in country b
weren't as good as they thought it might
have been initially so they start to
panic and they start wanting to unwind
their investments so whatever they had
in country b they want to sell it they
get b's currency for it and they want to
convert that to their home currency so
now you have the reverse situation of
what we saw in the last video
everyone wants to sell their b's
so they had invested in country b maybe
they bought some real estate there
they're going to sell their real estate
they're going to get b's for it and then
they're going to get out of that
country's currency they want to they're
going to want to convert that money back
into a's but this is the opposite
situation now everyone wants to run out
of country b
and there isn't there isn't a lot of
supply of a's in return no one's really
looking to trade a's for b's now
everyone is irked the market is going
completely in the opposite direction
now if once again foreign exchange
markets were allowed to flo float freely
what would happen
well in this situation all the demand is
for the a's and all of the supplies on
the b's so you would have
you would have either more
let me write it this way you would have
fewer a's per b
fewer
a's
per b
or you could have more b's per a
more these are the same statement more
b's
per a in general a has now become more
expensive in terms of b or b has become
more has become cheaper in terms of a
but let's say you're the central bank
you're like well i don't like this
either now all of a sudden especially
and usually this unwinding this panic
happens much faster and more dramatic
fashion
than the initial phase over here you say
oh my god people in our country they
might not be able to uh if if this were
to happen foreign imports would become
so expensive people might not be able to
even
afford food that we have to import from
other countries or or essential supplies
from other countries so they say no
we're going to intervene we were able to
accumulate some of these foreign
currency reserves and so we can use
those now to try to stabilize our
currency so in this situation what the
central bank would do is okay i've got
some reserves of a what i'm going to do
is i'm going to go into the open market
i'm going to go into the open market and
also sell my reserves
and sell
my reserves of a and try to
equalize the supply and the demand and
so once again if they're able to sell
these reserves now all of a sudden their
currency will not devalue or maybe not
devalue as much now the one kink in the
system here is that they only have a
finite they only have a finite amount of
reserves this right over here
is finite in the previous video when we
saw that they were printing their own
currency to buy to build reserves they
could do this all day all night because
they have the right to print as much of
their own currency as they want but now
they're using reserves of someone else's
currency to keep their own currency from
being devalued but they don't they can't
print someone else's currency so they're
they're they're hoping that they what
they have on hand is enough to to fight
this what they're probably perceiving is
a short-term imbalance but it could be
scary what happens if all of this
currency runs out then they blow all
their currency reserves and if this kind
of panic keeps occurring then you're
going to go back to the free market
forces and their currency will have to
devalue so that's kind of a currency
well that that's how central banks fight
uh attempt to keep their currencies
relatively stable
in future videos we'll go through real
cases of when this happened and what
exactly happened when the foreign
currency reserves ran out and how
speculators could use that knowledge to
essentially
make
an easy speculative buck